ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. DEGREE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW LOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN TO CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KAMLAGER KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERTRIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE THING WELL THERE IS THE
APPROVED VIA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THIS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN YES SIR AMONG ASHER.
IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. AS
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PEOPLE. WE HUMBLY ASK YOU. MAKE
US AN INSTRUMENT OF YOUR PEACE.
WHERE THERE IS HATRED. HELP US
SO LOVE. WHERE THERE IS DESPAIR
HOPE. WHERE THERE IS DARKNESS
LIGHT. WHERE THERE IS A DIVIDE
UNITY. GRANT US GUARD THE
ABILITY COURAGE AND WISDOM TO
ATTAIN ALL THESE OBJECTIVES FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I MEAN. THANK
YOU MOM YES HERE WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY ARE TELL AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER C. A. R. T. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
OUR GREAT NATION'S FLAG. READY
BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES.
ZERO YEAH. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
CHAIRMAN SACRAMENTO FRIDAY
FEBRUARY TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE ASSEMBLY MEDIT NINETY
ONLY AUDIBLE REBEKAH BAUR QUE
HAN ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK TO PARK AT THE DESK
READING FOR DAVID BOWMAN
READING THE ROLES CALLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONDAGE RADIUS
MOVES. MISS WALDRON SECONDS THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. THE
NEW MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MAYES
RAYOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
WARD SHOOTING IN BLOOM TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. WE WILL BE AWAITING
ACTION IN THE SENATE.
MEMBERS
AG IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS TODAY IS
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON'S
BIRTHDAY THE SPEAKER HAS JOINED
US ON THE FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE SPEAKER
RENDON AROUND APPLAUSE AND WISH
HIM HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS
WHILE WE ARE AWAITING ACTION IN
THE SENATE. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
AT THIS TIME. AS SUCH MEMBERS I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. AND OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MEMBERS. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION MEMBERS. WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
LET ME TRY TO SUMMERTIME
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
OR TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE CLEAR THE AISLES OF
CONVERSATION. WHERE THE GERMANS
TO MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART
THAT I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF LARRY TITO BAZA A
DEAR FRIEND A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR THE ARTS AND AN
ICONIC LEADER FOR THE LATINO
AND LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITIES IN
SAN DIEGO. HE WAS A KIND AND
EFFECTIVE FORCE IN OUR WORLD
AND HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON SO
MANY LIVES INCLUDING MY OWN.
LEARY'S PASTOR FOR THE ARTS
WENT FAR BEYOND HIS FINE ART
GALLERY IN LITTLE ITALY. AS HE
BECAME INVOLVED WITH MANY SAN
DIEGO ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CENTRO CULTURAL DE LA
RAZA ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHICANO MEXICAN AND INDIGENOUS
AMERICAN CULTURAL CENTERS IN
THE SOUTHWEST. WHERE HE SERVED
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. HE
BROUGHT A VISION OF UNIVERSAL
INCLUSION AND ACCESS TO THE
ARTS THAT WOULD EVENTUALLY LEAD
TO HIS APPOINTMENT ON THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. BY THEN
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER TONI ATKINS
WHERE HE WAS ELECTED CHAIR BY
HIS COLLEAGUES THIS PAST
DECEMBER. LARRY WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CHICANO PARK
IN BARRIO LOGAN HE PARTICIPATED
IN STRIKES AND BOYCOTTS
ORGANIZED BY THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS. AND EVENTUALLY BECAME
CO CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO PRIDE
COMMITTEE IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO. LARRY LIFTED UP OTHERS
JUST BY BEING HIMSELF. HE
LISTENED HE LOOKED TO
COMPASSIONATELY IN THE EYES HE
CARED ABOUT YOU AND MEET YOU
WANT TO CARE. WE LOST LARRY
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO AS HE
BATTLED HOLDEN. WITH OVER FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
LOST TO THIS PANDEMIC I NEED
SOULS MISSED AN IMPORTANT IS
THAT THE PARTICULARLY PAINFUL
WHEN WE LOSE SOMEONE WHO GAVE
SO MUCH TO THE COMMUNITY. THE
OUTPOURING OF GRIEF THOUGHTS
AND MORE HAS BEEN EXTENSIVE.
CONSTITUENTS HAVE USE THE
DESCRIPTIONS BEACON OF
POSITIVITY INCREDIBLE HUMAN.
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE WARRIOR
TITAN TRAILBLAZER HUMOROUS
SNAPPY DRESSER. I USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECITE IN HIS
WORDS IN A RECENT LOS ANGELES
TIMES INTERVIEW WHICH I THINK
IS APPROPRIATE FOR US TO ALWAYS
REMEMBER. I'VE BEEN VERY
ASSIMILATED AND A LOT OF WAYS
BUT WHEN YOU WORK IN THE EYE OF
THE STORM IN THE HOUSE THAT WAS
BUILT UPON. THE STRUGGLE TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
LIKE ME TO MAKE CERTAIN
ADVANCES OR REACH CERTAIN
LEVELS OF ABILITY IN EDUCATION
EVERYTHING BECAUSE A PART OF
THAT STRUGGLE. WE CAN'T FORGET
WHAT WE ARE NOT A PART OF WHAT
WE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO. AND
HOW MUCH FURTHER WE HAVE YET TO
GO. LARRY LEAVES US A LEGACY
AND A CULTURE TO ASPIRE TO.
LIVE UP TO AND TO CONTINUE
FIGHTING FOR AND WE WILL. HE'S
GOING MEAN KEEPING LARRY AS
HUSBAND HAHNEL AND THEIR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS IN YOUR THOUGHTS AS
WE ENTER IN THE MEMORY TODAY OF
LARRY TITO BASEL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR WARDEN. MISTER
DAVID CHIU YEAR RECOGNITION THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES IT
IS WITH THE DEEPEST RESPECT AND
SADNESS THAT ON BEHALF OF MY
CITY. I RISE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF LAWRENCE FERLINGHETTI.
WORLD FAMOUS POET PUBLISHER AND
FOUNDER OF THE ICONIC CITY
LIGHTS BOOKSTORE WHO PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE. WELL MISTER FROM THE
GETTY PLAN A ROOTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S NORTH BEACH
NEIGHBORHOOD FOR SEVENTY YEARS.
HE SPENT HIS LIFE EXPLORING THE
WORLD SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
FRONTIERS THROUGH THE WRITTEN
WORD. AS AN ORPHAN AND LATER AS
A WORLD WAR TWO NAVAL
COMMANDER. MR FROM GETTING
DEVOURED ANY BOOK HE COULD LAY
HIS HANDS ON. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE HE OPENED CITY LIGHTS THE
FIRST INDEPENDENT BOOKSTORE IN
THE COUNTRY. TO DEAL AN
INEXPENSIVE PAPERBACKS A
REPOSITORY BOOKS AND OTHER
BOOKS SELLERS IGNORE. CITY
LIGHTS QUICKLY BECAME A HUB FOR
AUTHORS WHO WROTE THOSE BOOKS.
AND AS A PLACE FOR POLITICAL
DISCUSSION IT IS EASILY ONE OF
MY FAVORITE SPOTS IN OUR CITY.
A PLACE WHERE SO MANY OF US
HAVE LOST YOURSELVES FOR HOURS.
IN THE YEARS AFTER YOU OPEN
CITY LIGHTS HE EMERGED AS A
SPIRITUAL GODFATHER OF THE BEAT
MOVEMENT. BEFRIENDING AND
CHAMPIONING MANY OF THE
MOVEMENT'S MAJOR FIGURES. HE
WAS ARRESTED FOR PUBLISHING BE
POURED OUT GAME ALLEN
GINSBERG'S POEM HOWL. AN ACT
WHICH AUTHORITIES FEARED SPREAD
QUOTE LEWD AND INTO THIS DECENT
WRITINGS. MISTER FRANK GEHRY'S
FIRST MINUTE VICTORY IN THAT
CASE MARKED A CRITICAL MOMENT
IN SHAPING HIS PHILOSOPHY OF
POETRY AS INSURGENT PART.
SHORTLY AFTER PUBLISHING HOW HE
WAS ATTACKED FOR BLASPHEMY IN
HIS OWN POETRY COLLECTION CONEY
ISLAND OF THE MIND. HIS
DETERMINATION TO PUSH
ACCEPTABLE BOUNDARIES RESONATED
WITH READERS THIS COLLECTION
REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL AMERICAN POETRY
BOOKS EVER PUBLISHED. IT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT MR
FERLINGHETTI. THE FIRST POET
LAUREATE OF SAN FRANCISCO WAS
AN ICON TO OUR CITY. HIS LEGACY
WAS HIS UNAPOLOGETIC
QUESTIONING OF DOMINANT
POLITICAL VIEWS AND CULTURAL
VALUES WHICH IS EMBEDDED IN THE
POLITICAL CULTURE NOT JUST IN
OUR CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. BUT
IN OUR STATE. FOR MANY OF US AS
WE WALK THROUGH THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND CAFES OF NORTH
BEACH. IT WILL BE HARD NOT TO
BE REMINDED OF THE SPIRIT OF
LAWRENCE FERLINGHETTI. HIS
SPIRIT WILL LIVE ON THROUGH HIS
POETRY HIS ACTIONS THROUGH CITY
LIGHTS. MAKE YOUR OWN LIGHT
CONTINUE TO SHINE ON LAWRENCE
FERLINGHETTI. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER TAKE YOUR ALSO
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU WOULD
SPEAK ALSO TO RISE. TO JOURNAL
MEMORY OF LAWRENCE FERLINGHETTI
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES. FROM SAN
FRANCISCO REALLY ECHOED A LOT
OF THE BIOGRAPHY AS WELL AS THE
SENTIMENT. THAT HE LEADS US
WHERE. THERE ARE VERY FEW. AYE
COMIC BOOKSTORES IN THIS
COUNTRY. BUT THE CITY LIGHTS
BOOKSTORE THAT HE FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THEM. IT'S
NOT JUST THE BOOKSTORE WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD COME FROM WITHIN
THE CITY BUT THAT TOURISTS
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THEY WOULD
STOP ON THE WAY AS THEY WERE
VISITING. IT HAS BECOME A
BEACON FOR PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT LITERATURE. EVEN AT A
TIME WHEN INDEPENDENT
BOOKSTORES HAVE REALLY BEEN ON
THE WAY. THEY HAVE SURVIVED
BECAUSE THEY OFFER SOMETHING
UNIQUELY. SAN FRANCISCO. I
DON'T THINK IT'S TOO MUCH TO
SAY THAT. HIS PRESENCE IN HIS
BOOKSTORE HAVE REALLY HELPED
KEEP SAN FRANCISCO VERY MUCH AT
THE LITERARY CENTER WITHIN NOT
JUST CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY
WITHIN OUR ENTIRE COUNTRY. AND
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN REALLY
RECOMMEND A VISIT TO OUR CITY
WITHOUT RECOMMENDING THAT ON
YOUR WAY THROUGH NORTH BEACH OR
CHINATOWN YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU STOP BY THE CITY LIGHTS
AND- SPEND SOME TIME THERE AND
BROWSE THE BROWSE THE ARNOLD
AND- MAKE SURE YOU CAN. FIND
SOME OF YOUR FAVORITE BOOKS.
HIS IMPRINT ON OUR CITY BUT
ALSO ON OUR CALIFORNIA CULTURE.
CANNOT BE UNDERESTIMATED HIS
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE BEAT
GENERATION. HIS INVOLVEMENT
WITH CHALLENGING THE STATUS QUO
REALLY CHALLENGING THE
THINKING. OF OUR SOCIETY. WHEN
HE STARTED THE BOOKSTORE THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES SEPARATE
FISCAL. REFORM REPUTATION FOR
THE WAS VERY MUCH NOT THE-
REPUTATION IT HAS TODAY. THE IT
REALLY WASN'T SEEN AS A PLACE
OF CHALLENGING THE NORMS VERY
MUCH SEEN AS- MUCH MORE OF A
BUTTON DOWN CITY I THINK. VERY
MUCH A MUCH MORE CONSERVATIVE
THIRTY. AND HIS HIS. STORE HIS
LITERATURE HIS THINKING. REALLY
HELPED. SHAPE OUR CITY INTO THE
CITY THIS TODAY. AND WITH THAT
I REQUEST THAT WE RESPECTFULLY.
ADJOURNED TODAY IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR A GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF IV BOTH KENYA WILL TEENY
WHO'S BEEN DESCRIBED BY MANY AS
AN LGBTQ COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
EXTRAORDINAIRE. IV WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX IN LONG
ISLAND. AND HER FATHER WAS A
CAB DRIVER AND BOXER WHO- I. V.
AS AN ONLY CHILD WAS TOLD BY
HIM. I YOU'RE A GIRL AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEFEND
YOURSELF AND LITTLE DID SHE
KNOW HOW MUCH FIGHTING SHE
WOULD BE DOING IN HER LIFE.
IVY'S FATHER WAS TRAGICALLY
KILLED WHEN SHE WAS A TEENAGER
LEADING TO A DEEP FINANCIAL
TROUBLES FOR HER AND HER MOM
LUCKILY I THESE ARTISTIC
TALENTS WERE RECOGNISED IN THE
FORM OF A SCHOLARSHIP TO THE
PRATT INSTITUTE. OF ART AND
DESIGN WHERE SHE BEGAN A CAREER
DOING ILLUSTRATIONS FOR A
NEWSPAPER AS A RESULT IVY WAS A
LONG LIFELONG ARTISTS. HER
FEMINIST AND LESBIAN ACTIVISM
TO TRACE THEIR ROOTS TO THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN I BE HELP
TO CO FOUND THE NE YORK CITY
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE SHE
DESIGNED THE LOGO FOR THAT
ORGANIZATION AND THEY STILL USE
IT TODAY. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE I BE RELOCATED TO LOS
ANGELES AND JUMPED HEADFIRST
INTO LGBTQ ACTIVISM BY CO
FOUNDING THE COALITION FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS. THE LOS ANGELES
LESBIAN GAY POLICE ADVISORY
BOARD. AIDS NETWORK LA AND H.
AIDS PROJECT LA NOW KNOWN AS A
P. LA HEALTH. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PROTEIN YOU WAS
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF NO ONE SIX THE
CAMPAIGN THAT DEFEATED THE
BRIGGS INITIATIVE WHICH WOULD
HAVE OUTLAWED GAYS AND
LESBIANS. FROM TEACHING IN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE SHE WAS
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN IS
COMMISSIONER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING MAKING HER
THE FIRST OUT LESBIAN OR GAY
PERSON. TO BE APPOINTED TO A
STATE BOARD OR COMMISSION. IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE PROTEIN
THE CO FOUNDED THE NONPROFIT
GROUP GAY AND LESBIAN ELDER
HOUSING WHICH IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN DEVELOP TRIANGLE SQUARE
THE FIRST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPLEX FOR GAME LESBIAN
SENIORS IN THE UNITED STATES.
INHER LATER YEARS SHE STILL
REMAINED A POWERFUL FORCE IN
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD AND
BEYOND IT WAS KNOWN FOR BEING
PASSIONATE AND FEISTY AT PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND SPOKE TRUTH TO
POWER IN LOS ANGELES AND WEST
HOLLYWOOD FOR NEARLY HALF A
CENTURY. FOR THOSE WHO KNEW HER
PERSONALLY SHE'S BEEN DESCRIBED
AS THE GRANDMOTHER MOTHER AND
FRIEND THAT EVERYBODY WANTED TO
HAVE IN THEIR CORNER. BOTTINI
PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR THE PASSION
THAT SHE BROUGHT TO OUR LIVES.
COMMUNITY AND FIGHT FOR JUSTICE
WILL BE TRULY MISSED SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTERS LAURA
AND LISA HER DAUGHTER IN LAW A
BATH AND A GRANDSON AND I ASKED
WE ADJOURN. IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM. THANK
YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES THE DEATHS REPORTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS TO
INTERMEMBRANE WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
WE ARE BACK TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WHILE WE
ARE AWAITING ACTIONS FROM THE
SENATE- WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD PLEASE RETURN OF
THE FLOOR WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR A VOTE. WE ARE GOING TO BE
VOTING MOMENTARILY PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR. MEMBERS WE
ARE AT CONSENT CALENDAR. THEIR
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP THE RESOLUTIONS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE ONE ROLL
CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY MEMBER
TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTIONS. THE CLERK WILL
READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
ONE BY SIN REMEMBER GRAYSON
RELATIVE TO FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS HOUSE RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN BY SIN REMEMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS FOR ALLEGEDLY YOU
WANT SUNDAY. AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO RARE DISEASE DAY.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE
ROLE TO ALLOW. CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTIONS THE PURPLE OVER THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS. IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON
CONSENT PLEASE ADD YOUR NAME AT
THIS TIME. THIS IS FOR CAL
AUTHORS. FOR THE RESOLUTIONS ON
CONSENT. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT.
THE CLERK WILL. BECAUSE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL APPLY
THAT VOTE TO THE RESOLUTIONS
THAT ARE ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR MOVING TO A VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF TO
CITY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING DONE THE%
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
RELATIVE TO FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VERY SAD ABOUT THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THE
CLERK WELL. THE CLOSER ROLE.
TITA I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CLERK WILL READ THE READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
POUNDS RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHT
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINE FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN ZERO ZERO INSTINET
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TEN FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN. NO ZERO.
MEMBERS
WE ARE. WE'LL BE BACK TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MS RAMOS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE. ASSEMBLY RULES
SIXTY THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
TO TAKE A AB EIGHTY SIX
RELATIVE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
RELIEF. AND REOPENING SCHOOLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. MISTER FLORA
WHAT PURPOSE- WE WITHHOLD
EMAILS BECAUSE CONSENT ASTRAL
CALL MR FLOOR AS WITHHOLDING MS
REYES MOVES MR BONTA SECONDS ON
THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MAYES
RADIUS IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE MS RAMOS IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE TO MR FLORA I
KNOW THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
ON SUSPENSION OF THE RULES.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL IS REYES
ASKING FOR AN I. MISTER FLOOR I
KNOW THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
EYES WITH YOU KNOW SIXTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS
IS. AB. EIGHTY SIX. MEMBERS.
PLEASE THE RETENTION MISTER TEN
COURT AGREED ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER KING EMAIL
PRINT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE PROBABLY RISE TO PRESENT
AB AT SIXTY LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL RE OPENING
PROPOSAL. AS A PARENT OF TWO
PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN WHO'VE
BEEN ON ZOOM FOR ALMOST A YEAR
NOW I SHARE THE FRUSTRATION
THAT SO MANY OTHER PARENTS
SHARE ACROSS THIS ENTIRE STATE
IN ASKING THE QUESTION WHEN
WILL SCHOOLS. REOPEN UP. WELL
THIS PROPOSAL. IS NOT
EVERYTHING THAT EVERY PARENT
WANTED OR THAT EVERY EDUCATOR
WANTED OR THAT EVERY DISTRICT
WANTED. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE BEST PLAN MOVING FORWARD
DOUBLE GET OUR SCHOOLS OPEN IN
AS MANY SCHOOLS OPEN AS
POSSIBLE IN THIS ENTIRE STATE.
I JUST WANT TO FIRST THANK SO
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THIS
CHAMBER AS WELL AS OUR STAFFS.
WE STARTED THIS YEAR WHEN WE
CAME BACK ARE VERY ONE OF OUR
VERY FIRST BILLS AB TEN. TO
SEND A MESSAGE ON HOW MUCH WE
THOUGHT ABOUT RE OPENING
SCHOOLS AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
WAS AND HOW IMPORTANT ISSUE WAS.
SO THAT DISCUSSION GOT JUMP
STARTED IN NOVEMBER LEADING
TOWARD THE DECEMBER BILL
INTRODUCTION. WHICH IS REALLY
GOTTEN US TO THIS POINT IN AB
EIGHTY SIX SO A. B. EIGHTY SIX
AUTHORIZES TWO BILLION DOLLARS
TO GO TOWARD SCHOOL RE OPENING.
EVERY DISTRICT WILL GET THE
MONEY AND IF THEY DON'T RE
OPEN. SOME OF THAT MONEY WILL
HAVE TO BE RETURNED AT SOME
POINT. WHAT IT DOES IS IT HALF
THAT. DAHLE DISTRICTS IN PURPLE
THAT ARE UNDER A TWENTY FIVE
PER ONE PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CASES HAVE TO OPEN TKA
THROUGH TWO CLASSES IF YOU'RE
FLOWN READ YOU HAVE TO OPEN ALL
YOUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CLASSES
AND AT LEAST ONE GREAT IN YOUR
MIDDLE OR HIGH SCHOOL. THIS IS
ON TOP OF ALREADY ASKING THE
DISTRICTS BRING BACK THEIR SAFE
COHORTS. FOR T. K. THROUGH.
TWELVE IN ADDITION TO FOUR
POINT FIVE SIX BILLION DOLLARS
FOR LEARNING RECOVERY WE KNOW
THAT EVERYBODY WHO HAS BEEN
EVERY STUDENT WHO HAVE BEEN ON
ZOOM TRYING TO LEARN HAS HAD A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF LEARNING LOSS
SO WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT FOUR
POINT FIVE SIX BILLION DOLLARS
WENT. TO HELP WITH LEARNING
RECOVERY. 85% OF THOSE
RESOURCES NEED TO BE SPENT. ON
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IN
DISTRICTS HAVE. FROM NOW TILL
THE END OF NEXT SUMMER SO THAT
THIS SUMMER NEXT SUMMER NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR. TO REALLY. ENSURE
THAT THEY CAN GIVE. EVERY
STUDENT IN THE STATE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN GET THEM CAUGHT BACK
UP TO SPEED AFTER. THIS VERY
CHALLENGING COVERT NINETEEN
TIME. IN ADDITION THE STATE IS
SETTING ASIDE 10% AGAIN 10% OF
THE STATE'S VACCINATION FASTED
FOR EDUCATORS AND CHILD CARE
WORKERS SO WE CAN GET SCHOOLS
RE OPENED UP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. AND THEN JUST LASTLY.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT HAVE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FRUSTRATIONS THAT
SCHOOLS THE PLANS BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EDUCATORS ARE SAFE FOR THE
STUDENTS ARE SAFE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER SAFETY
PLAN TO HAVE HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED BY. MARCH FIFTEENTH.
WITH THAT. AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
ECHO MY APPRECIATION FOR ALL MY
COLLEAGUES IN PARTICULAR. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH- FOR
REALLY WORKING SO HARD
COUNTLESS HOURS OF THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND REALLY. MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARRIVED AT THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
TANK MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB EIGHTY SIX THERE'S  LOT
CONTAINED IN THIS FORTY SEVEN
PAGE BILL. IT HAS REFERENCES TO
TEARS INTO THE DO'S AND DON'TS
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE TO ABIDE BY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY. IT
COMES DOWN TO THIS. WILL
PARENTS AND STUDENTS SEE THEIR
SCHOOLS AT ALL LEVELS. TKT
TWELVE OPEN UNDER THIS BILL.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THE RE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT IS
THE DEFINITION OF THE REOPEN
SCHOOL KIDS IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND WHAT YOU'LL HEAR IS THAT
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A FLOOR.
FOR WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. IN
PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE TO TAKE
THE FIRST STEP. MEMBERS SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE ACTED BUT
I WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT WE ARE
WAY BEYOND. FIRST STEPS. I'M
AFRAID THE EXPECTATIONS OF THIS
BILL. DOES NOT MEET REALITY.
THE LONGER SCHOOLS STAY SHUT
DOWN THE ACADEMIC CHALLENGES
GROW WE KNOW THAT. THE
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS OF OUR CHILDREN GROW
LARGER. ANXIETY DEPRESSION
SUICIDE OUR PARENTS ARE SEEING
THIS OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SEEING
THIS WE ARE SEEING THIS EVERY
DAY MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE
FIRE PERSONALLY SPOKEN WITH
EDUCATORS STUDENTS
SUPERINTENDENT. PERRANCE
DOCTORS EVERYONE IN BETWEEN
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF SCHOOL
RE OPENING. THERE IS NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THAT WE NEED TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS AT ALL LEVELS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WE CAN DO
IT SAFELY. AND WE CAN DO IT NOW.
WE ARE SEEING SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE NATION IN SOME
IN OUR STATE OPENING NOW FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. THE CDC.
HAS PUT OUT GUIDANCE SAYING
THAT SCHOOLS CANNOT REOPEN
SAFELY. OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
ENDURED THROUGH CONFUSING
RESTRICTIONS TEARS MANDATES AND
GUIDANCES IT IS THE STATE THIS
STATE THAT HAS IMPOSED THIS AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL OBSTACLES
THAT ARE HOLDING OUR SCHOOLS
BACK AND IT IS THIS STATE THAT
YOU REMOVE THOSE OBSTACLES AND
REMOVE THEM NOW. THIS BILL JUST
CREATE A NEW LIST OF RULES AND
MANDATES THAT HAVE TO BE
FOLLOWED. AND WHAT WILL OUR
STUDENTS SEE. AN HOUR OF IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. THREE HOURS
FOUR HOURS BEFORE THEIR SCHOOL
WILL BE TWO DAYS A WEEK. WILL
IT BE THREE DAYS A WEEK. WE
DON'T KNOW. IT'S NOT SPECIFIED
IN THIS BILL OUR STUDENTS NEED
TO BE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM NOW
BECAUSE IT IS THE BEST PLACE
FOR THEIR WELL BEING. AND MY
COMMUNITY I HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH SAFETY REVIEW
WAIVERS PENDING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
LET THEM REOPEN SAFELY AND
QUICKER. THAN THIS BILL. THIS
BILL. KEEPS OF THOSE SCHOOLS IN
THE BILL. AND DISTRICTS WILL
CONTINUE TO FACE UNCERTAINTY IN
AN ALREADY DIFFICULT SITUATION.
THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF THEY
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS BILL IN
ITSELF DOES NOT REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO REOPEN THE L. A. TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD EVEN OPINES
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT SPEED
UP THE RE OPENING OF SCHOOLS.
QUICKLY AND SAFELY RE OPENING
OUR SCHOOLS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PRIORITIES FACING OUR
STATE RIGHT NOW. UNFORTUNATELY
THE PARENTS STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS WHO WANT TO BE BACK IN
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO THAT. AND IT CAN BE
DONE. THAT'S PUT FORTH A BILL
THAT OPENS UP THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL STUDENTS OF ALL GRADE
LEVELS TO BE BACK IN SCHOOL
FIVE DAYS A WEEK I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS FONG. THIS
QUICK SILVA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTY SIX SAY SCHOOL PLAN
FOR ALL. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT JUST SPOKE IT'S
NOT A PERFECT BILL. BUT MUCH OF
OUR LEGISLATION IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. AS A TEACHER OVER
THIRTY YEARS I RECOGNIZE HOW
VITAL NOT ONLY EDUCATION IS BUT
IN PERSON EDUCATION. MY HUSBAND
IS A TEACHER TEACHING JUNIOR
HIGH RIGHT NOW AND OUR DISTRICT
HAS BEEN BACK SINCE OCTOBER
GIVING THE PARENTS A CHOICE
WHETHER TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL. IN PERSON OR TO DO A
HYBRID OR EVEN AT HOME LEARNING.
I SEE THE STRUGGLES FIRSTHAND
WITH GETTING STUDENTS TO LOG ON
GETTING STUDENTS TO TURN ON
THEIR CAMERAS. AND WHY BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING INTO THEIR HOMES
THEY'RE SHOWING PARTS OF THEIR
LIFE THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN SEEN
BEFORE. SO ALL RIGHT TO. KNOW
THAT WE HAVE MUCH TO DO. TO GET
SCHOOLS BACK READY TO BE OPENED
BUT WE MUST NOT SAY NO TODAY.
IN LIEU OF THE PERFECT. WE HAVE-TO SAY IT'S TIME IT'S TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO BE BCK TO SCHOOL.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO SAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN OPEN
PRIVATE SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS
THANK YOU WE KNOW YOUR JOB. HAS
NOT BEEN EASY. I CAN TELL YOU
TEACHING FROM ZOOM AND HAVING
STUDENTS IN THE CLASS AT THE
SAME TIME IS A JUGGLING ACT.
AND MANY OF OUR TEACHERS HAVE
DONE THAT. BUT I URGE A YES
TODAY. BUT ONCE WE GET STUDENTS
BACK IT'S ONLY THE FIRST STEP
WE MUST AFTER ADDRESS THE
TRAUMA. THE TRAUMA FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THE TRAUMA FOR OUR
TEACHERS AND STAFF AND WE HAVE
A LONG ROAD TO GO BY I HEARD
AND I VOTE TODAY. ON AB EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
THIS PARA QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN I'VE HAD
A FRONT ROW SEATS. FOR THE LAST
YEAR. FOR WHAT IT MEANS TO ASK
OUR CHILDREN TO MAKE THE
SACRIFICE THEY HAVE MADE. TO
STAY OUT OF THE CLASSROOMS AND
OFF THE PLAYGROUNDS. I'VE HELD
MY SIX YEAR OLD IS HE CRIED
THAT HE COULDN'T DO ONE MORE
MINUTE ON ZOOM. I SAT ON THE
FLOOR OF MY DAUGHTERS SHE BAGS
TO BE BACK ON THE PLAYGROUND
WITH HER FRIENDS. I SAT AT THE
COUNTER FOR ENDLESS HOURS
DOING. COMMON CORE MATH WHICH
IS MANY YOU KNOW IS A
CHALLENGE. AND SPELLING WITH MY
ELEVEN YEAR OLD TO MAKE SURE HE
GOT WHAT HE NEEDED. AND I SEEN
THE MENTAL AND PHYSICAL TOLL
THAT THIS IS TAKEN ON OUR
CHILDREN. AND A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO OUR DISTRICT IS ONE OF THE
LUCKY ONES THEY GOT TO RETURN
TO CAMPUS. AND I GOT TO SEE MY
CHILDREN LATE BACK UP. I GET TO
SEE THEM START SLEEPING AGAIN.
I GOT TO SEE THE JOY THAT IT
BROUGHT HIM TO BE BACK WITH
THEIR FRIENDS. AND EVERY
CALIFORNIA CHILD DESERVES THAT.
NO MATTER WHETHER THEY'RE IN A
BIG DISTRICT ARE SMALL IN ONE
WITH RESOURCES OR ONE WITHOUT.
AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO I'M
SUPPORTING AB EIGHTY SIX TODAY
BECAUSE IT IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION. AND LET ME BE CLEAR
IT IS A STEP. WE HAVE SO MUCH
MORE TO DO. AND I AM FOR ALL OF
YOU. TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
SENATE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH THE TEACHERS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATORS WITH OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS AND TO SETTLE FOR NO
LESS THAN OUR CHILDREN BACK IN
SCHOOL AT LEAST BY THE FALL
FULL TIME. ON THE PLAYGROUND
WITH THEIR FRIENDS IN THE
CLASSROOM LEARNING GETTING THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE FOR THE
FUTURE THAT THEY DESERVE THAT
IS WHAT CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
DESERVE. BUT LET ME NOT LEAVE
OUT CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN. THEY
HAVE LEFT THE WORKFORCE IN
GREATER NUMBERS THAN I THINK
ANY OF US COULD HAVE
ANTICIPATED BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHEN THE CHILD CARE BURDENS GET
GREAT. IT IS CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN
IN THIS NATION'S WOMEN THAT
BEAR THAT BURDEN. AND SO THEY
LEFT THE WORK FORCE AND SO FOR
THE GENERATIONS BEFORE US THAT
FOUGHT. FOR WHAT EQUITY WE HAD
WE HAVE TO GET OUR KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO DO IT AND WE
CAN DO IT SAFELY AS YOU HEARD
MY COLLEAGUE SAY AND AS WE
HEARD FROM THE DATA. SO WE MUST
FUNDS THE MEASURES TO DO IT
SAFELY GET OUR CHILDREN ON BACK
ON CAMPUS AND GIVE THEM THE JOY
THAT I SEE IN MY CHILDREN'S
EYES WHEN THEY COME HOME EVERY
DAY TO TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED ON
THE PLAYGROUND. SO THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE HAVE MUCH MORE WORK
TO DO. I KNOW THAT TOGETHER WE
CAN DO IT I KNOW THAT WE CAN
SEE OUR KIDS BACK WHERE THEY
DESERVE TO BE. AND I WILL TAKE
THIS FIRST STEP AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE FUTURE STEPS
AHEAD. THANK YOU IS PARA QUE
HAN. DR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS. THE WORD THERE IS ARE
IN PERFECT. AS ALWAYS THIS BILL.
BUT OUR BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY. FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
THE SERGEANTS AND THE YEAR
EXPLICIT HAVE PULLED US ALL WE
CAN SAFELY REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS
TO AND THE RETURN ON WHAT
CHILDREN TO CLASSROOM LEARNING.
WE HAVE BEEN- PORT TO LISTEN TO
THE EXPO CENTER FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE. AND THE CDC DIRECTOR
HERSELF WILL SERVE THAT THE
BOTH A PITCHER SEND THOSE
CHILDREN'S CAN SAFELY ARE TO
RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE DAMAGE TO
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING AND OUR
STUDENTS ARE MENTAL HEALTH
ACOSTA BY YOUR YEAR ALL OUR
DISTANCE LEARNING. IT HAS COST
A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS TODAY WE
ARE MARKING THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
DECLARATION ABA STAYS SHUT DOWN
BY THE GOVERNOR EXACTLY ONE
YEAR. IN OFFICE ENOUGH THIS
BILL AB EIGHTY SIX WAS OUR ONLY
SUPPORTABLE LAST WEEK- FOR
SEVERAL REASONS AND I CHECKED
WITH MY SCHOOL ORDER OF A
COUPLE OF LAW SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE AND THAT
THEY WERE OPPOSING. AND ON
ALMOST ALL PREPARED BUT THE I'M
SO GLAD THAT THE SOME OF THE-
IMPORTANT POINTS I HAVE BEEN
THE WORKED OUT. I HEARD THE
FROM MANY LOCAL LET'S CATION
OFFICIALS WHO SAID IT WAS ALL
ONE WORKABLE. AND DOT WOULD
ONLY LEAD TO A FURTHER DELAY IN
RE OPENING HOWEVER KNOWS MANY
OF THE- OBJECTIONS HAVE BEEN
NOW CLEARED. FROM THIS SAW A
MAN. AMENDMENTS THE AMENDED
BILL- BEFORE ALSO TODAY S. ARE
SUPPORTED BY OUR MY LOCAL AS
WELL AS SO MANY OF THE SCHOOL
WERE OFFICIALS SO AS YOU HAVE
SEEN IN THE ATTACHMENT ALONG
WITH THIS TO ALMOST SCORED A
DISTRICTS OR AS WELL AS SOME OF
TONY'S SAW AND THE
SUPERINTENDENTS OF. SO WELL. I
WILL NOT HONESTY YES ARE BACK
IN SCHOOL AS SOON AS A POSSIBLE
IT HAS BEEN ALL ALL LONG
OVERDUE I WOULD BE ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
HOWEVER- WAUTOMA LIKE TO SEE
OUR TO GO FURTHER. ON THE BILL
THIS IS WHY I ALSO SUPPORT THE-
PUT THE AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE
APPARENTLY ARM IT WAS ARE LAID
OFF ARE AT THOSE ARE SENATE
VERY. IT WOULD HAVE. ALL RECALL
TO SCHOOL. ALL FOR ALL GRADE
SAW. LEVEL THE- ALL GRADE
LEVELS TO ALL FOR THE OPTIONAL
BALL FIVE DAYS CORD LEARNING.
AT THE UP IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
JUST START LIMITING ONE DAY AND
SEVERAL HOURS AND THEN ALSO- TO
WORK. WEBER FRAZIER ARE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT NOW WE
NEED TO OPEN THE SCORING AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE FOR ALL
GRAYSON AND FOR FIVE DAYS SO
ALL SCHOOL NETWORKS ELEMENTARY.
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
THE DOES STOPPING AT THOSE ON
SECOND GRADE THE HORN OF THE
JUSTIFICATIONS WITHOUT THE WHAT
SCIENCE IS A BEHIND THE LET ME
TAKE THE BEATING OUT TO KATE
OUR SECOND GRADE. SERVILIA IT
APPEARS. THEY ARE MORE POLITICS
THAN NON SCIENCE OF AND SOME OF
THIS OPPOSITION SO WHICH IS WHY
I SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ARE NOT THAT LISTA THIS SAW AB
EIGHTY SIX OH OPENS UP BY
SMALLER DOOR AN ALLY I HEAR
THAT THE SOME OF THE. ARE
LIMITED TO. ON NUMBER OF ALL.
DOES THE UNIONS ARE AND ARE A
TEACHER SO OUR OBJECTIVE THIRTY
SECONDS AFTER CHOI HOW HOWEVER
HOWEVER MOST OF THEM ARE
OPENING DESIRE TO RETURNTO
SCHOOL. IN PERSON SO IF YOUR
DAD'S CATERS IF YOU ARE GOOD
THE LEADERS SO I HOPE WITH YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND DON'T
OPEN UP THE SCHOOL AS SOON AS A
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE I ASKED
YOU ARE BOOKED. THANK YOU DR
MISSED ONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE AS
A MOM. A TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
CHILDREN ATTENDING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SINCE KINDERGARTEN. AND
NOT JUST AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR ALMOST A YEAR NOW SCHOOLS
HAVE REMAINED CLOSED AND KIDS
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO LEARN FROM
HOME EITHER FULL TIME OR HYBRID
SCHEDULE. IT HAS BEEN BEYOND
FRUSTRATING AS A MOM WHAT YOU
MIGHT OWN EIGHT AND TEN YEAR%
OLD SON'S PHYSICAL. SOCIAL
MENTAL AND THAT THE ACADEMIC
WELL BEING DETERIORATED. THIS
IS A TEST THIS IS TAKING A TOLL
ON NOT ONLY MY FAMILY. OUR
FAMILY BUT THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
PARENTS LIKE MYSELF. ALL ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE SCREAMED AND
YELLED FOR HELP SINCE LAST YEAR.
TO DEMAND THAT OUR CHILDREN BE
ALLOWED TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE WE HAVE WITNESSED FIRST
HAND AND HOW DAMAGING IT HAS.
BEEN FOR OUR CHILDREN. WE'LL
POLICY GRADIENT EDUCATION GAP
THAT OUR CHILDREN WOULD NEVER
RECOVER FROM. EVEN WORSE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS JUST A FEW
MILES AWAY FROM HERE. HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREDIT TO OPEN. FOR A
LONG TIME MANY PARENTS IN MY
DISTRICT CAN'T AFFORD PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. AND TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE FOR SOME PARENTS IN MY
DISTRICT ENGLISH IS THEIR
SECOND LANGUAGE. FAST PLEASE
FAST SPEED INTERNET OR EVEN
HAVING INTERNET IS DIFFICULT OR
NOT AVAILABLE TO THEM. SINCE
BEING HERE. I'VE BEEN PROACTIVE
IN FIGHTING TO HAVE OUR SCHOOLS
REOPEN FOR MONTHS BECAUSE OF
THESE CONCERNS. IF WE HAD MORE
SOLID WITH LEADERSHIP AT THE
TOP IN THE STATE ALL SCHOOL
WOULD AND COULD HAVE OPENED A
MONTH MONTHS AGO. Y. S. WHILE
AB EIGHTY SIX IS FAR FROM
PERFECT. IT DOESN'T SURE
SCHOOL- WE OPEN SAFELY AND
SOONER THAN WHAT WAS EXPECTED
TO BE MONTHS AWAY FROM NOW. OR
EVEN NEXT SCHOOL YEAR. WE
OPENED OUR SCHOOLS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR PARENTS.
AND CHILDREN IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO ALLOW
SCHOOLS ALREADY OPEN AND
OFFERING TO CONTINUE TO DO SO
WITHOUT HAVING TO CLOSE.
HOWEVER LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONTINUE TO NEED MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON SOME OF THESE
MANDATES. IMPOSED IN THIS BILL
SUCH AS ALLOWING THE SCHOOL TO
DECIDE THE BEST WAY TOO
EXPENSIVE. THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY FOR GRANTS
THAT WILL BEST SUPPORT THE
NEEDS OF ITS STUDENTS. AN
ADDITIONAL CONCERN IS THE
PROTECTION FOR SCHOOLS IN
REGARDS TO COVERT NINETEEN
LIABILITY. NOT ALL SCHOOLS ALL
THE SAME IN THE STATE THE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL WILL NOT WORK.
I'M HOPING THAT WE- CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE
MINISTRATION. AND WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE TO BRING THESE CONCERNS
OF AND FIND A SOLUTION OR
SOLUTIONS. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING S. B.
A. SIX BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD. FROM LAST WEEK. SO THAT
WE COULD WORK OUT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS WE SAW ON THIS THAN
THE BILL. LAST WEEK. I AGAIN. I
AM VERY HOPEFUL THAT WE
CONTINUE THESE. CONVERSATION TO
ALSO HELP OUR MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS GET BACK SOONER
THAN LATER. ONE OF SHARES QUICK
STORY. WITH YOU LASTWEEK. I
WAS IN MY CAR DRIVING MY
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL. I WAS ON A
ZOOM CALL. TALKING ABOUT. RE
OPENING AND HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION. AFTER AFTER BIRTH
RIGHT BEFORE I WALKED MY TWO
BOYS TO CLASSROOM. MY TEN YEAR
OLD STOPPED ME AND SAID. MOMMY
WAS THAT ABOUT RE OPENING
SCHOOLS. AND I SAY YEAH HE GOES.
WE NEED THE SCHOOL BACK PLEASE
WE NEED A BACK. AND I LOOKED AT
HIM IT BROKE MY HEART. I SAID
WE'RE TRYING HONEY WE'RE TRYING
WE WILL DO IT WE CAN'T DO THIS
YOU NEED TO GO BACK HE SAID.
THANK YOU AND THEY GAVE ME A
HUG AND WILL OPEN AND IN WALKED
IN. OUR CHILDREN THAT. TO
CONTINUE NOT TO REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE IS
DETRIMENTAL THE FUTURE OF OUR
CHILDREN. THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
MISS KEY DID DEVELOPMENTAL
SOCIAL AND ACADEMIC ACTIVITIES
THAT THEY WOULD NEED FOR THE
FOR THEIR FUTURE SUCCESS. THANK
YOU JUST ONE. MR MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY SIX OUR
SCHOOLS STATE SCHOOL RE OPENING
BELL- THIS IS BEEN AN ELUSIVE
TASK TO BRING THIS TO THE
FLORIDA VOTE- BEFORE US IT
CERTAINLY TOOK A BIT MORE TIME
THAN WE WOULD HAVE LIKED AS OUR
EYES ARE AUTHOR AND SHE BUDGET
CHAIRMAN NOTED WE STARTED THIS
CONVERSATION IN NOVEMBER. WHEN
ABOUT A HALF A DOZEN OF US
LAWMAKERS TO FROM SAN DIEGO
FROM SAN FRANCISCO LONG BEACH
HUNTINGTON BEACH. CONTRA COSTA.
WE WERE STATE WE WERE IN THE
PURPLE THEN AND WE WERE SEEING
WHAT'S HAPPENING ALL OF US HAVE
KIDS AT HOME. ALL OF US WERE
ZOOM PARENTS. AND WE WERE
SAYING THAT HAPPENS WHETHER OWN
KIDS BUT ALSO WE ARE SEEING THE
INEQUITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WITH KIDS GOING BACK TO SCHOOL
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WEALTHIER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE THOUGHT
WE SAW THAT JUST WASN'T.
EQUITABLE AND FAIR FOR ALL OF
US. FAST FORWARD WE WILL CHRIS
WENT TO THE PURPLE STAGE. WE
WENT THROUGH THE SPIKE OVER THE
WINTER NOW WE'RE AT A BETTER
SPACE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
DOIG THIS ANYWAY. WE TOOK OUR
TIME WE NEGOTIATED WITH THE
SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE WE HEARD URBAN
DISTRICTS. RURAL DISTRICTS WE
HEARD FROM LABOR AND MANAGEMENT
AND FOCUSED WHAT'S REALLY
NEEDED WHAT CAN HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THEY **** ONE THING
ABOUT THREE FOUR WEEKS AGO.
LIKE WE HEAR IN MEDICINE DO NO
HARM. ALLOW US TO DO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE NATURAL ANYWAY.
THE PROVIDE US MORE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO HELP US OPEN UP.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS. IT
FOCUSES ON WHAT WE'VE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR. VACCINATIONS
IT'S HAPPENING ANYWAY SOMETIMES
VERY LUCKY THAN GOOD GOOD
TIMING RIGHT HERE WE'RE HAVING
A HUGE INFUSION ACROSS THE
NATION COMING. TO CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PRIORITIZING 10% FOR OUR
EDUCATORS OUR TEACHERS ARE
CLASSIFIED WORKERS AS WELL AS
OUR CHILD CARE WORKERS. SO
CLEARLY THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO
SPUR DISTRICTS ON THE SIDELINES
TO ACT. AND ALSO HELP THAT
THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY ACTING.
I WISH IT WAS STRONGER MANY OF
US WISH I HEAR MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA ANA TALKING ABOUT
TAKING HER KIDS TO SCHOOL. I
HAVEN'T TAKEN MY KIDS TO SCHOOL
IN A YEAR. I CAN'T WAIT. FRIDAY
THE THIRTEENTH AS MANY OF YOU
REMEMBER WAS THE LAST DAY THAT
I TOOK MY KIDS TO SCHOOL ON THE
DROP OFF PERSON IN OUR AND OUR
FAMILY AND IT'S BEEN ALMOST A
YEAR. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT. WHEN
WE GO BACK THE REALITY TO SOME
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. ARE
ONLY GONNA BE GOING BACK. FOR
MAYBE A DOZEN DAYS IF YOU LOOK
AT THE HYBRID LEARNING OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU'RE SAYING
BEST CASE SCENARIO. GO BACK MID
APRIL. SHUT DOWN MID. JUNE
YOU'RE GONG A COUPLE DAYS A
WEEK LOOK AT THE CALENDAR.
THAT'S DOING EIGHT DROP OFFS.
EIGHT DROPS SO WHAT DOES THAT
REALLY MEAN. THE SECOND PART OF
THIS BILL THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO PUSHED US TO
FOCUS ON. IS THE KEY THING AND
THAT'S LEARNING LOSS. BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT GOING AWAY WE OPEN
AT SCHOOL NEXT WEEK AND TWO
WEEKS. NOT MAGICAL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET. KIDS BACK AS FAR
AS WHERE THEY NEED TO BE.
ACADEMICALLY THE PACE RESEARCH
THAT CAME OUT A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IS UNBELIEVABLY DAMAGING TALK
THAT THAT SHOWS THAT THAT WHAT
KIDS ARE ARE FALLING BEHIND
WHICH KIDS ARE FALLING BEHIND.
AND NOT SURPRISING. ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. A FOSTER YOUTH
AT KIDS IN FRONT OF BLACK
COMMUNITIES. THEY'RE LEARNING
LOSS IS SEVERE SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T JUST.
THINK THIS IS A PANACEA AND
MOVE ON. THIS LEARNING LOSS
ISSUE IS REAL. WE DO HAVE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO FOCUS ON.
ADDRESSING THAT THIS SUMMER ALL
THE WAY THROUGH NEXT SUMMER.
FOCUSING ON IN PERSON BECAUSE-
OF. MORE ZOOM SCHOOL IS NOT
GOING TO CURE THE WELLS. OF THE
ZOOM SCHOOL IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO WE NEED TO REALIZE THAT IS
THERE IS A REALITY AND WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT THIS AGAIN
WHEN WE ADOPT OUR FINAL BUDGET
IN A FEW WEEKS WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT WHAT THIS MEANS.
OTHER CALLING FROM CONTRA COSTA
TALK ABOUT GOING BACK IN THE
FALL MAXIMIZING IN PERSON. BUT
REALIZING THIS LEARNING LOSS
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
JUST. MOVE ON FROM THIS IS THAT
CLEARLY THE ISSUE OF THE DAY.
NOT JUST RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
WITH ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE ASKING US TO
HELP DO. BUT MAKE SURE WE FOCUS
ON. OUR STUDENTS HUMAN MAKE
SURE THOSE KIDS SUCCEED. AND
THEY ARE CERTAINLY THE FUTURE
OF OUR ECONOMIC WELL BEING
CALIFORNIA SO THIS. IS A
POSITIVE BUILT WITHIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS EMBRACE IT- ACROSS
THE STATE. I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO HELP AND I'M JUST
pGONNA STEP UP RIGHT AWAY. DO
THE RIGHT THING. MY DISTRICT
HERE. THEY'RE FIGHTING OVER
WHAT COLOR THIS GUYS EVERY DAY.
AND WE HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND
KIDNEYS DISTRICTS AND RIGHT
HERE IN OUR HOME CITY. WHO WANT
TO GO BACK LIKE OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA TALKED ABOUT HER
LITTLE SON I'M NOT I WANT TO GO
BACK THESE KIDS WANT TO GO BACK
SO WE'RE PUTTING THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE WE HEARD YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
VACCINES. SO I'M CALLING ON ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING CALIFORNIA'S
WATCHING AND WE DEMAND. THAT WE
STOP UP AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YU MR MCCARTY MISS RUBIO
IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO STATURE IN
SUPPORT SB EIGHTY SIX. AS A
FIRST STEP. TO GETTING OUR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL I DO WANT TO.
POINT OUT A COUPLE OF ISSUES. I
HAVE EIGHTEEN DISTRICTS IN MY-
IN MY DISTRICT. ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND- ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING IS THAT EVEN THOUGH LA
COUNTY'S. TEAR IS READY FOR RE
OPENING IN MY DISTRICT ARE
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES HAVE A
HIGHER RATE OF INFECTION. AND
THEY THE COMMUNITIES AFRAID OF
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL SO I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. ABOUT HOW WE
ASSIST THOSE DISTRICTS. THAT
HAVE A HIGHER RATE AS- HIGHER
RATE THEN THE REST OF THE
COUNTY THAT'S THE ONE ISSUE THE
OTHER ISSUE I WANT TO ADDRESS
IS. THE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ARE HAS BEEN
PROVIDED FOR OPERATIONAL
READING READING IS WHAT I HEAR
FROM MY DISTRICTS AS WELL IS
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION AND
FUNDAMENTAL SHRUB. SERVICES TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS CAN RETURN
TO SCHOOL SAFELY SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS- IN
PARTICULAR THAT THAT HAVE THE
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION- AS A WAY
OF GETTING TO SCHOOL IS NOT
BEING ADDRESSED. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT C. H. P. HAS THE
RESOURCES TO CERTIFY THE NEW
SCHOOL BUT BUS DRIVERS IN A
TIMELY MANNER. IF SCHOOLS OPEN
TOMORROW MANY STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GET BACK IN THE CLASSROOM
BECAUSE ALL TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES HAVE NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED SO I WOULD LIKE. US
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION-
THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY THOUGHT ABOUT AS A
ISSUE TO- AS AND- BARRIER TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS WHICH IT ISN'T
HOWEVER A LOT OF OUR VULNERABLE
STUDENTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT TO SCHOOL IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THE TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAYES RUBIO. IS PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I ALSO WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THE SPELL
AND FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA KIDS- I RISE TODAY
AS A MOM TELL. HER PREVENTIVE
PARENTS TODAY LIKE SO MANY OF
YOU MY TWO BOYS WHO ARE IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AT APPROACHING
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY SINCE
THEY ENTERED A SCHOOL
DAY
HAVE EVERY ADVANTAGE IN EVERY
AVAILABLE RESOURCE THEY'VE GOT
A COMPUTER THEY'VE GOT WIFI
THEY'VE GOT TWO PARENTS WERE
THERE TO HELP THEM. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S STILL REALLY
REALLY HARD. AND I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA KIDS. THAT IS NOT
TRUE THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT AND EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE SHATTERED.
IT'S THOSE KIDS WHO ARE FALLING
FURTHER AND FURTHER BEHIND. AND
IT'S THOSE KIDS THAT WE NEED TO
BE FIGHTING FOR. THEY DON'T
HAVE LOBBYISTS I DON'T HAVE A
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE THE
DON'T HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
THE ONLY HAVE PASSED IN THEIR
CORNER. FIGHTING FOR THEM. SO
WE NEED TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT WE
NEED TO OPEN THEIR SCHOOLS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE THING IS. WE ARE
CREATING A TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF
EDUCATION. HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT. RICH
DISTRICTS. THAT PRIVATE SCHOOLS
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS HIS DOORS
OPEN OPEN FOR MONTHS IT'S IN
OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. WHERE
THE SCHOOLS ARE STILL SHATTERED.
THAT SHOULD BE ANATHEMA TO ALL
OF US. AND WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT WE CAN CHANGE THAT
TRAJECTORY SO I AM SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE IT IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
NOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
FUNDING THAT SUPPORTS THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
IN THIS BILL IT REALLY IS JUST
THE FIST STEP WE NOW NEED OUR
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE OUR
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ARE
SCHOOL BOARDS AND OUR TEACHERS.
TO STEP UP AND STEP IN
ALONGSIDE US SO THAT WE CAN
SAFELY RE OPEN OUR SCHOOLS AND
DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA
CARD. WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR PRIVACY. THANK YOU
MISTER NORTH. MISSED GONZALEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK THANK YOUMISTER SPEAKER-
I WANT TO START BY THANKING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BECAUSE- THIS WAS NOT EASY AND
REALLY THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU
SHOWED- WAS INCREDIBLE OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. I'M IT STRIKES ME AND
HEARING EVERYBODY SPEAK THAT.
JUST LIKE THIS PANDEMIC IN SO
MUCH WE TALK ABOUT THAT WE ALL
KIND OF LIVE IN DIFFERENT
WORLDS- I LIKE MANY PEOPLE.
HAVE BEEN HOME WITH MY KIDS-
FULL DISTANCE LEARNING FOR THE
LAST YEAR. AND IT HASN'T BEEN
EASY A THREE. KIDS AT HOME BOYS
M. ALL TRYING TO BE ON THEM AT
THE SAME TIME AND I KNOW THE
CHALLENGES. BUT I ALSO LIVE IN
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
HARDEST HIT BY THIS PANDEMIC.
AND THAT THE FEAR OF PARENTS
AND TEACHERS RETURNING ISRAEL.
IT'S A REAL FEAR BECAUSE OF
SOMEBODY BRINGS HOME COALBED
SOMEBODY MAY DIE. IT'S NOT JUST
A NASTY FLU IT IS DEATH THE
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST COVERT RATES THE
HIGHEST DEATH RATES IN THE
LOWEST VACCINATION RATES SO I
KNOW PEOPLE REALLY ANXIOUS TO
GET THEIR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL
IN EVERY COMMUNITY. BUT THERE
IS JUSTIFIABLE FEAR IN SOME OF
OURS. AND SO I'M OF COURSE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT SOME THE LEARNING
RECOVERY LANGUAGE WE GOT IN
HERE THAT WAS YOU KNOW THE
PIECE THAT THAT I WAS SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH OF COURSE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO REVISIT
THIS BUT- I KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING BUT THERE ARE A
COUPLE THINGS I JUST. WANT TO
POINT OUT. THERE WERE
NEGOTIATIONS MADE BASED ON TIER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE BEING CHANGED
NOW. IT'S KINDA NOT FAIR YOU
KNOW I JUST WANNA BE REALLY
HONEST SO WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE
THE TEARS AND SUDDENLY
EVERYBODY'S AND READ HERE THAT
CHANGES THE CLASSES THAT HAVE
TO BE OPEN THAT NUMBER CLASSES
IN THE TESTING CADENCES. SO IF
YOU GET CALLS FROM YOUR
TEACHERS UNION A LITTLE UPSET
THEY THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
UPSET YOU DON'T NEGOTIATED DEAL
AND THEN CHANGE THE PARAMETERS
THAT DEAL ON THE DAY THAT WE'RE
VOTING ON IT AND I THINK THAT'S
JUST WEEK WE HAVE TO BE HONEST
ABOUT THAT IT'S A LITTLE.
DISHONEST WHAT'S HAPPENING. THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH. MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN GABRIEL VALLEY. IF YOU
LIVE IN A DISTRICT. WHERE THE
COUNTY IS SURE MOVING INTO THE
RED HERE. BUT IT'S YOUR PORTION
OF THE COUNTY THAT'S PULLING
EVERYBODY DOWN. I GUARANTEE YOU
I DON'T HAVE THE SAME RATES. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM INSIDIOUS. WE
HAVE ALL THE CASES IN OUR-
IT'LL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SO WE
ARE BEING PULLED INTO THE RED
BY PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE AS
MANY CASES AND IT DOES. CREATE
A DISTURBANCE NOW I'VE TALKED
TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF MY
DISTRICT AND THEY'RE WORKING
HARD THEY HAVE BEEN. RE OPENING
PLANS A MEETING WITH THE
TEACHERS UNION THEY THEY HAVE.
A PLAN SET. BUT THEY'RE GOING
TO MISS OUT ON THE FIRST WEEKS
OF MONEY BECAUSE THEY WERE
ALREADY WORKING ON AN APRIL
TWELFTH ST. SO ALTHOUGH WE TALK
A LOT ABOUT EQUITY IN THIS
HOUSE IF YOU WILL. WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO ACTUALLY
DISTURBING FUNDS WE END UP
PUTTING IN RULES THAT
SOMETIMES. MEAN THOSE WITH THE
LEAST STILL GET THE LEAST. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
THEY WILL ALL BE PENALIZED
BECAUSE NONE OF THEM WILL BE
ABLE TO OPEN UP. ON THE DATE
THAT WAS SET IN THIS BILL. OKAY
STILL SUPPORT THE BILL THESE
ARE THE PROBLEMS. AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL BECAUSE I HOPE. THAT
THIS ISN'T THE LAST TIME WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS. RIGHT AS
MUCH AS- AS WE GOT INTO THIS
BILL ESPECIALLY LEARNING LOSS
AND LEARNING RECOVERY MONEY AND
THAT'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH. THE
DISPARITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
EXIST IN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
HAVE GROWN EXPONENTIALLY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. WE ARE WE ARE WE
DO HAVE MONEY AVAILABLE BUT
IT'S AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY
IT'S NOT FULLY TARGETED TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST ALTHOUGH WE HAVE AN
EQUITABLE A MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION. THEN THE
DISTRIBUTING IT EQUALLY BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING AT FORMULAS THAT
ARE MORE EQUITABLE. WE NEED
MORE AND I'M JUST GONNA BE VERY
HONEST ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
KNOW I'M NOT THE ONLY MEMBER ON
THIS FLOOR WHO'S GOING TO SAY
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE NEED
MORE WE NEED MORE TARGETED
MONEY IN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
BECAUSE IF YOU THOUGHT THERE
WAS AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP BEFORE.
YOU GUYS WERE GONNA BE PAYING
FOR THIS FOR TEN YEARS. IT AND
THERE HAVE BEEN KIDS LITERALLY
WHO HAVE NEVER LOGGED ON IN MY
DISTRICT. WE NEED TO DO MORE
THAN SIMPLY SAY WE CAN CATCH
THEM UP WE NEED TO PASS A BILL
THAT ALLOWS PARENTS THE RIGHT.
TO HAVE THEIR KID REDO THE
GREAT THIRTY SECONDS WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT PARENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INTERVENE ON BEHALF
OF THEIR CHILDREN. BECAUSE SOME
PEOPLE IT'S NOT THAT THE
TEACHERS HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB
THEY HAVE BUT WE NEED TO DO
MORE FOR KIDS BECAUSE SOME OF
OUR KIDS GOT NOTHING THIS PAST
YEAR. SO I JUST I HOPE WELL
ALTHOUGH FOR THIS AND I HOPE
WILL COME BACK AND CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THESE INEQUITIES THAT
HAVE GROWN IN TRULY INSURE OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING MORE MONEY AND TARGETED
MONEY AT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN HURT THE MOST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS CONSEILS
THIS VALIDATORS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY SIX WHICH
THEY'RE NOT PERFECT WILL HELP
MORE SCHOOLS OPEN SAFELY. I
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL OF THIS
AGREEMENT BECAUSE ITIS IN FACT
FAR FROM PERFECT THE BILL DOES
NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO HELP
REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY
OUR MIDDLE. AND HIGH SCHOOLS
ADDITIONALLY I WISH WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
NECESSARY AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL THAT WOULD PERMIT OUR
SCHOOLS TO BETTER SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS IN PERSON. EVEN SO
THIS BILL DOES GIVE AN
INCENTIVE FOR SCHOOLS TO OPEN
AND IT PROVIDES RESOURCES TO
AID THE TRANSITION TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. IT ALSO MAKES
PROGRESS IN VACCINATING OUR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF WHICH
IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS
PUZZLE. TO ME THIS BILL IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
DISTANCE LEARNING IS HARMING
OUR KIDS IN WAYS THAT WE MAY
NEVER BE ABLE TO QUANTIFY. AND
EVERY STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA HAS
A RIGHT TO A QUALITY EDUCATION
QUALITY IS KEY AND THUS IN
PERSON LEARNING SHOULD BE A
RIGHT. ABRAHAM LINCOLN. WHOSE
PORTRAIT SITS WATCHING US ONCE
SAID UPON THE SUBJECT OF
EDUCATION NOT PRESUMING TO
DICTATE ANY PLAN OR SYSTEM OF
RESPECTING IT I CAN ONLY SAY
THAT I VIEW IT AS THE MOST
IMPORTANT SUBJECT WHICH WE AS A
PEOPLE MAY BE ENGAGED IN. I
HAVE HEARD FROM HUNDREDS OF
PARENTS STUDENTS TEACHERS
ADVOCACY GROUPS THAT ARE
ENGAGED AND DESPERATE TO GET
THEIR STUDENTS BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM. THEREFORE THIS BILL
IS NOT DONE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO ADDRESS LEARNING LOSS THE
REGRESSION OF OUR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS ANXIETY DEPRESSION
SUICIDE. FOR DECADES TO COME.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO WORKWITH
OUR STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
TO OPEN. EVERY SCHOOL FOR EVERY
STUDENT OUR CHILDREN DESERVE
NOTHING LESS FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MICHELLE OTHERS
MR GALLAGHER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS YOU KNOW I
THINK ALL THE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS. AND
ALL OF US. HAVE FACED MANY
SIMILAR ISSUES MANY OF US ARE
PARENTS OF SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
AS I AM. AND I CAN TELL YOU IT
HAS NOT BEEN EASY AT ALL. TO
WATCH THOSE THREE CHILDREN GO
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND WHAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN OUR WHAT
HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING. IN OUR
SCHOOLS TO HAVE A MY OLDEST
DAUGHTER NOT BE ABLE TO FINISH
EIGHTH GRADE YEAR NOT TO HAVE A
GRADUATION. AND A START
FRESHMAN YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
COMPLETELY ON DISTANCE
LEARNING. FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
AND MONTHS. HAVE TO MISS OUT ON
THAT INTERACTION THAT SHE HAS
WITH HER TO SEE THE AFFECT. ON
HER MENTAL HEALTH. AND SO I
THINK. WE HAVE TO HAVE A SOBER
ASSESSMENT HERE TODAY AND WE
HAVE TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
GETS AN F. IT GETS AN F. IN HOW
IT DEALT WITH EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA DEEMED EDUCATION NOT
ESSENTIAL. THAT'S A FACT WE GET
MANY INDUSTRIES GOING OPERATING.
WE DEEM THOSE INDUSTRIES AS
CENTRAL AND WE DEEM SCHOOLS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES NOT A CENTRAL. AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED. AND IT'S
A TRAVESTY. THAT THAT HAPPENED
ON OUR WATCH. NO LONGER BE FAIR
I THINK THE LION'S SHARE OF THE
BLAME GOES WITH THIS GOVERNOR.
BECAUSE THE REASON THAT YOUR
SCHOOLS ARE NOT OPEN RIGHT NOW.
THE REASON WHY THE GENTLEMAN
FROM SACRAMENTO IN MY HOME
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE NOT OPEN
RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE OF THE
BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK. SCHOOLS
THAT WANT TO OPEN CANNOT OPEN
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN PURPLE TAR.
AND THE GOVERNOR IS THE ONE WHO
ESTABLISHED THAT POLICY NOT
WITH US. NOT IN THROUGH A DUE
PROCESS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THAT SHOULD BE THE WAY THAT
POLICIES ARE ENACTED. IN A
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT. BUT BY
ONE MAN MAKING ALL THOSE
DECISIONS AND THAT IS THE
REASON THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
STILL CLOSED IN MANY
COMMUNITIES IN FAR TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES IS BECAUSE OF THE
BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK AND THE
AUDACITY OF THIS MAN TO THEN
BLAME US. TO THEM BLAME THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY WE'RE
DRAGGING OUR FEET WHEN HE'S THE
ONE WHO HAS KEPT THEM CLOSED.
THIS WHOLE TIME. AND IF YOU USE
THAT ARBITRARY POWER HE COULD
OPEN SCHOOLS TOMORROW. BUT HE
IS NOT. THAT IS THE REASON WHY
WE WERE IN THE SITUATION THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES AND WE ALL
HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS. BUT LOOK
FOLKS LET'S BE HONEST THE CDC
IN DECEMBER SAID THAT WE COULD
OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY IN DECEMBER.
AND HERE WE ARE IN MARCH.
DEBATING AND FINALLY PASSING
SOME LEGISLATION THAT LOOK AT
BEST AT BEST FOR MOST SCHOOLS-
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA GET
SOME OPENED IN APRIL. IN A
HYBRID MODEL THAT WE'VE ALL
TALKED ABOUT IS DOES NOT WORK
FOR WORKING PARENTS. YEAH
THAT'S EASY FOR WORKING PARENTS
TO SAY OKAY I'M GONNA GO HALF
DAYS. DROP THE KID OFF AT IT
I'LL COME BACK AND PICK UP AT
NOON. ONE O'CLOCK HOW'S THAT
GOING TO WORK. AND WE ACT LIKE
THIS IS GOOD POLICY THAT WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE SOLVED ALL
THE PROBLEMS YOU KNOW BY DOING
THIS TODAY WE GET IN F.
CALIFORNIA GETS AN F. AND HOW
IT DEALT WITH EDUCATION PERIOD.
AND IT'S BEEN DEVASTATING WE
ARE GOING TO BE LIVING WITH
THIS. FOR MANY YEARS TO COME.
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT SOBRE
ASSESSMENT HERE. AND I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO IT IS INEQUITABLE. AS
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE ALREADY
GET SHORT CHANGED. AND HOW
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED AND MANY
OF THOSE SCHOOLS IN THOSE RURAL
AREAS ACTUALLY TOOK THE MONEY
FROM LAST YEAR AND THEY RE
OPENED AND THEY SPENT THE MONEY
ON P. P. ON. ON ALL THE THINGS
IT TAKES TO HELP REOPEN THE
SCHOOL SAFELY. AND THEY SPEND
IT AND SOME OF THE LARGER URBAN
DISTRICTS DIDN'T SPEND A DIME
OF THAT ON RE OPENING THEY
STAYED CLOSED. AND NOW UNDER
THIS NEW ALLOCATION THIS YEAR.
MY RULES ARE GOING TO GET SHORT
CHANGED ONCE AGAIN. AS THE
ALLOCATION STAYS THE SAME
THERE'S NO MINIMUM. ROLE
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT I AND
OTHERS HAVE ADVOCATED FOR IT'S
NOT IN THIS BILL. SO THERE IS A
DRESSED. THAT'S ISSUE THE
DIDN'T GET ADDRESSED. BUT LET'S
NOT FOOL OURSELVES WE SHOULD
NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN AGAIN.
WHAT OCCURRED WHAT OCCURRED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA MANY OTHER
STATES HAVE BEEN OPENED SAFELY
THEIR KIDS HAVE BEEN BACK IN
SCHOOL WE HAVEN'T. THAT IS
MOSTLY ON THE GOVERNOR BUT IT'S
ALSO ON US. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER O'DONNELL YOUR RECORD AT
YOUR DESK I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTY SIX I DO THAT AS
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE A PARENT OF TWO THAT
HAVE BEEN- LEARNING ONLINE FOR
THE LAST YEAR AND HAS NOT GONE
REAL WELL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
FOR SURE- AND ALSO AS A
TEACHER. ONE HAS BEEN IN THE
CLASSROOM FOR MANY YEARS- BUT
LISTEN THIS IS A GOOD BILL. GET
SCHOOLS RE OPEN AND ADDRESSES
LEARNING LOSS. IT HELPS
PRIORITIZE TEACHER VACCINES AND
ANYONE WHO SAYS A TEACHER.
SHOULD ENTER A CLASSROOM
WITHOUT BEING FAXED AND ICE
VACCINATED IS FOR MALARKEY
QUITE FRANKLY. TEACHERS NEED TO
BE VACCINATED IT KEEPS THEM
SAFE IT KEEPS OUR FAMILY SAFE
KEEPS OUR CO WORKERS SAVE IT
KEEPS THE STUDENTS SAFE. SO THE
SPEEDS UP GETTING SCHOOLS
REOPENED WITH SAFETY PROTOCOLS
BEING REQUIRED AN EDITOR
ADDRESSES LEARNING LOSS AND
ALSO THE SOCIAL AMONG SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF CHILDREN.
CAN BE ADDRESSED THROUGH THIS
LEARNING LOSS MONEY THERE'S
MORE TO DO BEYOND THIS BILL FOR
SURE THIS YEAR AND WE WILL DO
IT. WITH SUBSEQUENT ACTIONS BUT
TODAY I AM FULLY SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
RICHARD ALL MEMBERS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN DEBATE
RASCHER MICROPHONES AT THIS
TIME MR KILEY YOUR RECOGNITION
THE REAR CHAMBER. IN SOME PARTS
OF OUR STATE- OCCASIONALLY KIDS
WIL GET A DAY OFF FROM SCHOOL
FOR A SNOW DAY. WHEN THE STORM
PASSES AND THE SNOW MELTS. WE
DON'T SIT AROUND AND NEGOTIATE
ABOUT WHETHER TO OPEN THE
SCHOOL BACK UP. IT JUST OPENS.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S THERE FOR. NOW
THIS VIRUS OF COURSE HAS NOT
DISAPPEARED. FAR FROM IT BUT
WHAT VANISHED LONG AGO WAS ON
THE ONE HAND ANY PRETENSE THAT
THE OPERATION OF SCHOOLS PLAYS
A MEANINGFUL ROLE IN
TRANSMISSION AND ON THE OTHER
HAND ANY DOUBT THAT THE CLOSURE
OF SCHOOLS DOES SEARING HARM.
THAT HARM IS ESTABLISHED NOT
JUST BY THE UNIMPEACHABLE
FINDINGS OF STUDY AFTER STUDY
BUT BY THE TRAGIC LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF FAMILY AFTER
FAMILY. IT IS DECISIONS BY
PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING. AND
ONE PERSON IN PARTICULAR. THAT
IS BRINGING DEVASTATION
DEPRESSION LOSS AND DEATH THE
KIDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE KILLING OUR KIDS FOR
NOTHING. WE ARE KILLING OUR
KIDS FOR NO GOOD REASON. GAVIN
NEWSOM'S MONSTROUS SCHOOL
CLOSURES ARE AMONG THE GREATEST
GOVERNMENT CRIMES OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AT LEAST IN THE
NOMINALLY DEMOCRATIC WORLD. AND
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
COMPLICIT. SURRENDERING TO THE
SAME SPECIAL INTEREST IS THE
GOVERNOR. PARENTS OF YOUNG KIDS
HAVE GONE FROM HAVING TO
EXPLAIN WHAT A VIRUSES TO
HAVING TO EXPLAIN WHAT
CORRUPTION IS. THERE'S AN
EDITORIAL IN TODAY'S LA TIMES
HEADLINED SORRY WITH THE
STATE'S NEWEST DEAL ON SCHOOL
RE OPENING WON'T SPEED THINGS
MUCH. THE TIME SAYS THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN CARE OF
MONTHS AGO. BUT INSTEAD THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE AND MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS A CENTRALLY
ELECTED TO THE UNIONS TO THE
SIDE. THE RESULTS SADLY CHAU OR
EDUCATION LIES IN THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES. I PREPARED AN
AMENDMENT FOR TODAY. THE FALL
OF THE SCIENCE AND OPEN SCHOOLS
AS OTHER STATES HAVE. BUT THAT
AMENDMENT FAILED IN THE SENATE
THIS MORNING AND NOW THIS
ASSEMBLY IS GOING TO PASS A
BILL THAT DOESN'T GUARANTEE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR ONE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. THERE IS
NO ESCAPING THE SINGLE
BRUTALIZING FACT THAT WE HAVE
THE POWER TO END THIS MADNESS
AND A REFUSING TO DO SO. WE'RE
THE BAD SAMARITAN A PARABLE.
WALKING BY A SWIMMING POOL
SEEING A CHILD DROWNING AND
GOING ON WITH OUR DAY. I'M NOT
ASKING ANYONE HERE TO BE A HERO.
NOT ASKING YOU TO DIVE IN
HEADFIRST AND RUFFLE UP YOUR
SUIT. I'M JUST ASKING THAT WE
THROW IN A LIFE PRESERVER. WE
FIND A DASH OF HUMAN DECENCY IN
A CAPITAL OR DECENCY HAS NEVER
BEEN IN SHORTER SUPPLY. MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
READING A LETTER FROM ONE OF MY
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS MISTER TIM HIGHER
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME.
TO LISTEN AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
BASED ON THE INPUT FROM
EDUCATION LEADERS ACROSS THE
STATE. I BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS
MADE WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
SCHOOLS TO BRING STUDENTS BACK
TO CAMPUS AND DO SO IN A SAFE
WAY. TULARE COUNTY APPRECIATES
THE WINDOW BETWEEN NOW AND
APRIL FIRST. TO ORGANIZE AND
APPROVAL PLAN TO ACCOMPLISH OUR
COMMON GOAL. OF SAFE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. THOSE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE ALREADY PROVIDING IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WILL ALSO BENEFIT
FROM THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
AND WILL BE ABLE TO ADD MORE
STUDENTS AS PARENTS BECOME MORE
CONFIDENT. IN THE SAFETY OF
THEIR CHILDREN. WHILE ON CAMPUS
AGAIN. THANK YOU AND I FEEL
VERY POSITIVE ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS PLAN. MEMBERS
I STAND IN SUPPORT WITH MY
LOCAL SUPERINTENDENTS. AND
PARENTS I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
THEY'VE PUT IN OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS PUSHING AND
FIGHTING FOR AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THIS A BETTER BILL. HOWEVER. MY
SUPPORT DOES NOT COME WITHOUT A
SENSE OF CAUTION. AS WE ARE ALL
AWARE THIS IS WITHOUT A DOUBT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BILLS WILL
BE VOTING ON THIS YEAR. WITH
THAT BEING SAID. I DID NOT COME
TO MY SUPPORT LIGHTLY. I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THIS BILL GOES A
LONG WAY TO FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS
TO ENSURE THAT THIS RE OPENING
PROCESS IS NOT FINANCIALLY
BURDENSOME. NOR ARE THE TESTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT COME ALONG
WITH IT. I'M ALSO PLEASED THAT
WE MANAGE TO REMOVE THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
PORTION OF THIS BILL. ANY ROAD
BLOCK TO RE OPENING SIMPLY
HARMS OUR STUDENTS FARTHER.
LET'S BE CLEAR. OUR STUDENTS.
ARE SUFFERING WITHOUT ACCESS TO
EDUCATION OR SPORTS. FRANKLY
THIS PERIOD OF TIME IN OUR
HISTORY HAS BEEN THE WORST FOR
THEM EVER. TOO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ALREADY FALLEN
INTO GANGS DRUGS OR WORSE
SUICIDE. THESE HAVE ALL BEEN.
PERPETRATED BY THIS OVERLY
BURDENSOME CLOSURE OF OUR STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL STILL
LACKS SOME KEY COMPONENTS. I'M
STILL VERY TROUBLED BY THE FACT
THAT THIS PLAN DOES LITTLE TO
NOTHING TO BRING OUR MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS BACK. INTO
THE CLASSROOM. I AM FOR US TO
CONTINUE WORKING. ON THIS ISSUE
TO ENSURE ALL. OF OUR CHILDREN
CAN RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. SADLY WE CAN
ONLY VOTE ON WHAT IS BEFORE US
TODAY. WALDSCHMIDT THIS BILL IS
AN IMPROVEMENT TO THE PREVIOUS
VERSION. I AM ADMITTEDLY
SKEPTICAL OF OUR
ADMINISTRATION'S ABILITY TO
ENACT THIS BILL. LET US ALL BE
CLEAR MEMBERS. THIS PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE AIMING TO SOLVE HERE
IS NOT CAUSED BY US. NOR SHOULD
THIS SOLUTION WE'VE ALL WORKED
SO HARD ON. YOU SEEN AS A FIX
BY OUR GOVERNOR. RATHER THIS
PROBLEM HAS BEEN PERPETRATED BY
OUR GOVERNOR OVER THE PAST YEAR.
IT'S EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING TO
ME. THERE WERE HAVING TO VOTE
ON A MEASURE TO REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS WHEN WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ABILITY TO SOLVE
IT. WITH A PENCIL DRUG. AND
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF HOW MUCH HE
LOVES PAN. MEMBERS THE FAMILIES
WE REPRESENT HAVE BEEN BEGGING
US TO REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS FOR
MONTHS THIRTY SECONDS IT IS
HIGH TIME WE LISTEN TO OUR
FRIENDS. NEIGHBORS. AND GET OUR
KIDS BACK IN THE SCHOOLS AND
GET THOSE BELLS OPEN WITHOUT
MEMBERS I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ON AB EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I WANT
TO JOIN THE PARENTS THAT HAVE
RISEN ON THIS FLOOR TO TALK
ABOUT. THEIR FAMILY'S
EXPERIENCES. IN A FOR MAY ONE
OF THE IMAGES. FROM THIS
PANDEMIC IN THE DISTANCE
LEARNING EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT.
WELL AS SEEING BY SIXTH GRADE
DAUGHTER. ALONE IN HER BEDROOM
DOING JUMPING JACKS IN FRONT OF
A COMPUTER SCREEN. WE NEED TO
GET. OUR KIDS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM. AT THE SAME TIME YOU
KNOW I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT MY DAUGHTER AND MY FAMILY
WE HAVE MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER GOING BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S SAFE. AND
SO. IN AWE. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND ALL OF US. THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY I KNOW WE- TALK
ABOUT IT A LOT THAT. THE KIDS
NEED TO COME FIRST. BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO REMIND OURSELVES
I MEAN. TO PUT THE POLITICS
ASIDE WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS
ON WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE KIDS. YOU KNOW.
WE CAN'T JUST MAKE IT UP A
POLITICAL ISSUE TO REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS TO GET OUR KIDS BACK WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING IN A SAFE WAY. WE HAVE TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES. ALTHOUGH LEARNING
LOSS ALL THE MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS THE SOCIAL IMPACTS ON
OUR KIDS IN THIS DISTANCE
LEARNING. BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
RECOGNIZING THIS IS A REAL
PANDEMIC THIS IS A REAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND THAT'S A
DIFFICULT BALANCING ACT TO
BALANCE ALL THOSE INTERESTS.
BUT AGAIN I AS A PARENT. I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE
I BELIEVE IT'S IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT AS WE PUSH TO
GET OUR KIDS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING IT FOR
POLITICAL REASONS BUT WE'RE
DOING IT IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR KIDS. THANK IMAGE
MURATSUCHI MYSTERIOUS AND THE
REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I'D TO SEE
OPTICALLY STAND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I WAS ELECTED TO BE THE
VOICE. ARE THESE PEOPLE WITH
THAT SAID BY STAFF MYSELF SPOKE
HER SUPERINTENDENT'S. EIGHTY
EIGHT OUR TEACHERS OUR PARENTS
OUR STUDENTS ARE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THEM IS AT AB EIGHTY SIX
IS FAR FROM PERFECT. THERE IS
MUCH ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT IF I
WAS TO GIVE THIS BILL RIGHT NOW
AS IT STANDS GREAT. I'D GIVE IT
A C. MINUS. HOWEVER GETTING OUR
KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL SAFELY
OUTWEIGHS. WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW. I RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS
OF THIS BILL. INCLUDES
FINANCIAL TOOLS FOR OUR SCHOOLS
TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE STAFFING
WHICH IS NEEDED IT ALSO ALLOWS
ACCESS TO TEACHERS AND STAFF
FOR VACCINATIONS SO HOW DO WE
TAKE A C. MINUS. AND IMPROVE IT
NUMBER ONE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE FUNDING THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THOSE FOR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
I CAN TELL YOU FOR THE LAST
NINE YEARS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH FAMILIES. THAT HAVE HAD
CHILDREN THAT HAVE COMMITTED
SUICIDE. THAT HAVE A DRUG
OVERDOSES IN DEALING WITH
DEPRESSION. AND IT'S INCREASED
IMMENSELY THIS LAST YEAR BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDING THAT IS
IN THIS BILL FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
IT DOESN'T REPRESENT WHAT IS
NEEDED. THESE TEACHERS THESE
PARENTS ARE TELLING US THAT
THIS IS GOING TO GO ON ONCE WE
GET THE STUDENTS BACK IN SCHOOL
FULLY YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THE
EFFECTS OF THIS LAST YEAR. IT
ISN'T GOING TO BE OVER YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE KIDS THAT ARE
STILL GOING TO BE DEPRESSED
KIDS THAT NEEDS HELP SO WE NEED
TO HAVE BETTER FUNDING AND MUCH
MORE FUNDING AND NOT JUST A ONE
TIME FUNDING. THIS IS GREAT FOR
A YEAR WHAT ABOUT NEXT YEAR.
THESE TEACHERS ALSO THAT ARE
GOING TO BE GOING BACK NEED TO
HAVE SECURITY THE STUDENTS NEED
TO KNOW THEIR TEACHER WILL BE
BACK AFTER A YEAR. SO WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THAT. ONE THING THAT
I HAVE TO TELL YOU IS I'M SO
DISAPPOINTED. AND THE SCANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS SHAREHOLDERS.
DECIDED TO PUT TOWARDS
INCREASING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS. AND
LASTLY. I URGE CDPH TO GIVE OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE HOW THE
FORTY TO SIX FOR DISTANCING
USING GOOD FAITH EFFORTS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN OUR SCHOOLS. SO
THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE
TO SAFELY ATTEND SCHOOL FIVE
DAYS A WEEK AGAIN WE HAVE
LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S FORTY
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THESE
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL. WITHOUT
REALLY ANY CASES WE HAVE
SCHOOLS IN OUR DISTRICT THAT
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS AS WELL
AND THERE IS ZERO CASES SO WHEN
YOU SAY LET'S. LOOK AT THE
SCIENCE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN TOLD
LOOK AT THE SCIENCE LOOK AT THE
SCIENCE ALL THE WAY UP UNTIL
THIS POINT AND NOW THE SCIENCE
DOESN'T MATTER WILL BE LOOK AT
HOW THESE SCHOOLS HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN ABLE TO DO THIS SAFELY. SO
IT'S TIME THAT WE GO AND WE USE
LOOK AT SCIENCE- THIS DIRECTION
IN THIS DIRECTION. I WANT TO
KNOW THAT I WILL. I NEED TO SEE
EXACTLY VOTE YES ON THIS BUT I
ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I
WILL NOT GIVE UP. I WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR A PARENTS
FIRST STUDENTS UNTIL EVERY
CHILD IS BACK TO SCHOOL SAFELY.
FULL TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS DAVIS MISS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES- I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE IMPASSIONED
DISCUSSION WE'RE HAVING ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OUR SCHOOLS PLAY
IN OUR SOCIETY AND IN OUR
CHILDREN'S LIVES AND OUR FAMILY
LIVES. IN BEHIND THOSE SCHOOLS
THE EMPLOYEES THAT PLACE AND IN
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE NOT
JUST IN THIS MOMENT. BUT ADDED
ON TIME AND I THINK AT TIMES WE
FORGET THAT HERE I IN THE
LEGISLATURE. EYES ON I THINK
THAT DURING THIS PROCESS WE ASK
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO ADJUST TO ADJUST
TO REMOTE LEARNING. AND THEY
DID AND IT'S BEEN HARD FOR THEM
TO JUST LIKE FOR A FAMILIES WE
ASK THEM TO JUST A HYBRID
LEARNING. AND THEY'RE DOING IT
AND IT'S HARD. WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO RETURN TO THE CLASSROOM
AND AS A FORMER MATH TEACHER
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE PLACE WE NEED OUR
KIDS TO BE. BUT WERE AFRAID
BECAUSE YOU'RE ASKING TO PUT
OUR OWN LIFE AT RISK AND TO PUT
OUR FAMILIES LEFT AS RISK. I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I'VE BEEN TALKING TO
MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AND SO I
THE FAMILIES- FADE TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE OKAY THEY'RE NOT SURE
THAT THOSE KIDS ARE GOING TO
STAY SAFE OR THEY'RE GOING TO
BRING SOMETHING HOME TO THEIR
FAMILY TO. SPREAD THE DISEASE
AT HOME. NOT NOT ALL MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO RE OPEN I HAVE A RATE OF
INFECTION OF ONE IN. OF A DEATH
RATE OF ONE IN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY AND HAVE A VACCINATION
ABOUT ONE IN. TWENTY IN THE
CITY OF ALL GUARDIANS.
WEDNESDAY NOT LONG. IN THERE TO
SCHOOL. THE SCHOOL THIS. IS NOT
GONNA BE OPEN IN MY CAN. BUT I
ALSO HAVE SOME OF THE BIGGEST
LEARNING. AND THIS WILL BE. AND
I DO NOT KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING
TO CATCH UP WITH. BEEN BEHIND
AND I JUST HAVE NO CLUE HOW WE
GONNA CATCH UP. IN THIS
PROCESS. AND SO I'M GOING TO
VOTE I FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP. BUT IT'S NOT A STEP THAT
I'M SURE IS GOING TO HELP MY
COMMUNITY IN ANY WAY FIND THIS
THAT I'M SURE IS GOING TO HELP
MY MOST WINNABLE. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. AND SO AS THE WORK
CONTINUES I HOPE THAT THIS HAS
TO BE BROUGHT TO THE TO THIS
DEBATE. IS A PASSION THAT WE
BRING CONTINUOUSLY. TO FIX
INEQUITY THAT PRECEDED ALL OF
US IN THESE COMMUNITIES. AND TO
MAKE SURE WERE PAYING THE DUE
RESPECT BUT THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THE EMPLOYEES AND
THOSE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WE AT
THE END OF THE DAY. CARE ABOUT
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FUTURE
AND KNOW. THAT IT IS A GOOD
PLACE FOR THEM TO BE BACK. IN
THE CLASSROOM. AS WELL IT PAINS
ME. TO KNOW THAT HAVE KIDS THAT
ARE HOME SUFFERING. I PAINS ME
TO KNOW WE ARE BEING ASKED
MAKE. REALLY TOUGH CHOICES OUT
THERE. AND SO WE NEED TO DO ALL
WE CAN TO EXPEDITE VACCINES IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. I KNOW THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT THAT- BEFORE
FOLKS ARE OUT THERE WORKING ON
THIS. THE SOONER WE GET THESE
COMMUNITIES THESE HOTSPOTS
FAXING NEEDED. NOT TO SEE IF
YOU'RE A- TEACHER ARE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE OF THE
SCHOOL SITE. BUT JUST ANYONE IS
COMMUNITY THE SOONER THAT WE
LEVEL OUT THIS CURVE. AND WE
GET A COMMUNITY BACK TO DO. THE
GOOD WORK THAT THEY WANT TO DO
OUT THERE. AND SO I AM
COMMITTED TO THE WORK. OF WITH
MY COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE THE
pALSO MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
GOING TO BE OPEN IN SOME
CAPACITY AND WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SOME OF THESE
DOLLARS SO I DON'T WANT TO
PRETEND THAT. IT'S HELPING.
IT'S HELPING NO ONE OF MY
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY WILL
HELP A LOT OF FOLKS IN MY
COMMUNITY. BUT WE HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO UNTIL PLEASE
REMEMBER. THE IMPORTANT THAT
OUR SCHOOLS PLAY- ELLIS SO THAT
RESPECT. YOUR AROUND THE ****
DURING THIS MOMENT THAT WE ARE
ALL STILL DESPERATE. I TO GET
OUR KIDS BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM FOR WHATEVER REASON
OVER. WHAT COMING OUT HERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER.
MISTER GORE. GARCIA AND THE
REAR OF THE- YOU ARE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO. AND
SO. OF AB EIGHTY SIX AND
MOTIVATED BY THE BIPARTISAN
CONSTRUCTIVE NOTICE. OF THIS
CONVERSATION MANY OF YOU WHO
HAVE SPOKEN. HAVE CONTRIBUTED.
CONSTRUCTIVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US TO KEEP OUR EYE ON AND BRING
BACK. IDEAS AS PROPOSALS TO
CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE OF
IMPROVING THE ISSUES THAT EXIST
IN COMMUNITIES POOR COMMUNITIES
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
LACK THE RESOURCES TO CLOSE
THAT ACHIEVEMENT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATION AND THE
CONVERSATION TIED TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH INVESTMENTS THAT NEED TO
BE MADE AT THE SECURITY ISSUES
AROUND THE ISSUE OF THE VIRUS
FOR TEACHERS AND STAFF AT
SCHOOLS TO COME BACK. WHAT I
DON'T REALLY APPRECIATE IS THE
CIRCUS PARKING LIKE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY THOSE
WHO REPRESENT. SUBURB AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE NOT SEEN
THE SAME IMPACT. OF THIS VIRUS
AFFECTING THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS THAT IF YOU
REPRESENT A COMMUNITY THAT'S
POOR AND ONE THAT IS A COVER.
FAMILIES ARE NOT FEELING
COMFORTABLE. SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL
TEACHERS STAFF AND ALL THOSE
SUPPORTING. MEMBERS OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT COMFORTABLE
SENDING FACTORS. THAT GOING
BACK TO WORK AND HAVING
CHILDREN THERE. THE FACT IS
THAT YOU KNOW IN DECEMBER AND
IN JANUARY WE HAD NO VACCINES.
TO SEND PEOPLE BACK TO SCHOOLS
IN A SAFE. ENVIRONMENTALIST E.
REAL RIGHT AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
THE CIRCUS BARKING LIKE
COMMENTS HERE GOT A STOP.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT A REALITY
THAT MANY OF US HERE FACE IN
OUR DISTRICTS. THE FACT IS THAT
THIS IS A STEP. IN MAKING SURE
THAT OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
STUDENTS GO BACK SAFELY AND I
YOU KNOW I'M A PARENT. OF TWO
TEENAGERS SENIORS. AND THE
TRADE OFF HERE IS THAT- SENDING
THEM BACK TO SCHOOL FOR A
GRADUATION CEREMONY. OR THEIR
LIVES. THEIR LIVES WAY BEFORE A
GRADUATION CEREMONY. KERN OF A
SIX YEAR OLD WHO BY THE WAY
TESTED POSITIVE ALONG WITH
MYSELF MY WIFE AND OUR TWO
TEENAGERS. THE BIGGEST FEAR
THAT I EVER HAD CAME TO REALITY.
THAT ALL OF OUR KIDS WOULD GET
SICK AND LUCKILY THANK GOD NONE
OF THEM ENDED UP IN THE
HOSPITAL BY THEMSELVES. AND SO
THE FACT IS THAT THAT'S THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
AND WE LIVE IN AND SO WE TALK
ABOUT WE SHOULD OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS A LONG TIME AGO I'M
SORRY. YOU'RE LIVING IN A VERY
DIFFERENT REALITY THAN THE ONE
THAT MOST CALIFORNIANS LIVE.AND SO YOU KNOW I RISE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE NOT
ALTHOUGH NOT PERFECT. IT IS THE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS OPEN
UP SAFELY. AND THAT IT'S THE
BEGINNING OF OPENING UP. THE
ECONOMIES IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES EVERYTHING THAT
WE'RE ALL STRIVING TO DO AND I
THINK WE CAN DO SO. AS MANY OF
THE CONSTRUCTIVE BIPARTISAN
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN ADDED
TO THIS DISCUSSION- COULD LEAD
US TO IMPROVING THIS MEASURE
AND THE INVESTMENTS THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO
THIS ADMINISTRATION. FOR
PIVOTING AND BEGINNING TO MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS 40% OF
VACCINES GOING TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF HARDEST HIT.
POPULATIONS THAT SHOULD BE. THE
FLOOR WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTMENTS. IN OUR
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED
COMMUNITIES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL THEM OR DEFINED. THE DATA
DOES NOT LIE AND THOSE VACCINES
WILL BE GOING THERE TO HELP US
OPEN UP OUR SCHOOLS AND KEEP
OUR CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR TEACHERS SAFE AND I KNOW
THAT MY LITTLE GIRL IS GOINGTO
BE SUPER EXCITED TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL GIVEN THAT SHE'S A
SPANISH. LANGUAGE LEARNER THAT
BEING IN THE CLASSROOM WILL BE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
IMPACTFUL WAY FOR HER TO BECOME
BILINGUAL AND SUCCEED IN THEIR
STUDIES AND AGAIN I HAVE TWO
TEENAGERS I WILL BE GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL THIS YEAR AND
IF IT'S BETWEEN THE CEREMONY.
OR THEIR HEALTH AND WELLBEING.
WELL THAT'S WHERE I STAND- WITH
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING-
TOOL TIMIDLY BE SUCCESSFUL SO
AGAIN- I APPRECIATE THE
CONSTRUCTIVE BIPARTISAN.
DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE HAD TODAY
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE SHOW
THAT WE'VE GOT TO ALSO HEAR
FROM ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES WITH
THAT I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR GARCIA. MISTER GIBSON IN THE
REAR THE CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO THANK THE
GERMAN FROM STAFF AND SOME SAN
FRANCISCO THE WORKING EXTREMELY
HARD ON THIS ON THIS- BILL THAT
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE
A BI PARTISAN- SUPPORT AGAIN I
RISE TO SUPPORT AND THEN MY
VOICE IS WITH ALL THOSE WHO'VE
ALREADY SAID THEY SUPPORT THIS
AB EIGHTY SIX WHICH SET FORTH A
PLAN. FUNDING NEEDS TO RE OPEN
SCHOOLS SAFELY BY THE END OF
MARCH. WE MUST UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS PLAN IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS UNDERSTAND WORK IN
PROGRESS IT IS NOT THE BE ALL
END ALL BILL BUT IT'S A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT THIS
IS A DIFFICULT RESPONSIBILITY
THERE WE ALL HELD. WE ALL HILL
SINCE THIS PANDEMIC STARTED.
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
GO BACK TO THE CLASSROOM
PHYSICALLY. THIS IS ABOUT THE
STUDENTS. THEIR FAMILIES
STUDENTS ACROSS MY DISTRICTS
ARE STRUGGLING. TO KEEP UP
ACADEMICALLY AND WILL CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE IF THEY DO NOT
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THE LEARNING LOS. FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT EVEN DEALING
WITH THIS PANDEMIC ARE
STRUGGLING EVEN MORE. THERE
BEEN DEVASTATED. WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE YOUNG BRIGHT MINDS.
THAT COULD ONE DAY STAND ON
THIS FLOOR. ONE DAY BE THE
LEADERS AND BE THE CHANGE
AGENTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY. IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOT TO
KNOW. THAT MY DISTRICT HAS SOME
COURAGEOUS INDIVIDUALS WORKING
EXTREMELY HARD. THOSE ARE THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO STEPPED UP
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. TO
OVERCOME THESE CHALLENGES AND
THESE OBSTACLES. BROUGHT ON BY
THIS PANDEMIC MANYOF THEM HAVE
PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK. BUT
THEY DID A FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
THEIR COMMUNITY. TEACHERS
CONTINUE TO DO THEIR BEST DAY
IN AND DAY OUT TO SUPPORT THEIR
STUDENTS. UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS PANDEMIC HAS
EXPOSED THE INEQUALITIES THAT
HAVE PREVAILED FOR GENERATIONS.
AND WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO LET
OUR CHILDREN FALL FURTHER
BEHIND. COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT DESERVE A WORKABLE
PLAN TO MOVE US ALL FORWARD. WE
HAVE WORKED FOR LESS FOR FAR
TOO LONG NOW IS THE TIME TO
SHOW OUR STUDENTS OUR BABIES
OUR CHILDREN THAT THEY ARE
WORTH THE INVESTMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WAS STRONG I
VOTE FOR CHILDREN FOR OUR
STUDENTS FOR COMMUNITY OR AB
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU MEMBERS SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MR TANG YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. LET ME JUST THANK ALL
MARCH ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION. AND
DEBATE THAT WE'VE JUST HAD.
THIS DISCUSSION. DEMONSTRATES
WHY EDUCATION IS PROBABLY OUR
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE. BUT IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT IT'S
PROBABLY OUR TOUGHEST ISSUE. WE
HAVE OVER A THOUSAND DISTRICTS
IN THIS GREAT STATE OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. FROM URBAN TO
RURAL RICH TO POOR. WE ALL HAVE
VERY STRONG FEELINGS FOR WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS THE BEST THING TO
DO FOR OUR CHILDREN. AND I
BELIEVE THAT EACH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US. REALLY
HONESTLY BELIEVE. EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE FIGHTING FOR IS
REALLY WHAT'S BEST. FOR OUR
DISTRICTS. THIS IS A BILL THAT
HAS TO BE WHAT'S THE BEST FOR
OUR ENTIRE STATE. INDICT THEN I
FULLY RESPECT FOR MY COLLEAGUES
WHO REPRESENT. AREAS WERE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS LIVE BECAUSE
THEIR RATES ARE THROUGH THE
ROOF. THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
STAY AT HOME AND BEYOND ZOOM.
IS SO WE DO OWE IT TO THEM IN
THEIR DISTRICTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET THE PROPER.
VACCINATIONS THEY GET THE
HEALTH CARE THAT'S NEEDED BUT
WE HAVE AGAIN. THIS NON ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT
SINCE JANUARY THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
FOR. IT I WOULD SAY THAT THIS
BILL. IS HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE ADVOCACY FROM THIS BODY. IN
ONE OF THE REASONS I THINK THIS
BODY PARTICULAR CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT IT IS HOW MANY OF US ROSE
BECAUSE WE'RE PARENTS. BECAUSE
WE HAD A WATER KIDS. GO THROUGH
THIS. WE HAD TO SEE HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT A CONSTITUENT
TOLD US. WE GOT IT WE GOT A
REMINDER FROM THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONSTITUENTS. EVERY
SINGLE DAY WHEN WE GOT UP. YEAH
I HEAR YOU FROM OUR ROLL CALL.
I UNDERSTAND THE COOPER THE
CONCERNS THE ISSUES ARE
ABSOLUTELY. REAL AND THEY'VE
BEEN REAL THIS IS A DIVIDE THE
WE HAVE A CHALLENGE OF WE HAVE
THIS AMAZING STATE AGAIN TO
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE. THEN WE
HAVE CHALLENGES BETWEEN OUR
URBAN IN OUR RULE CALIFORNIA.
AT TIMES IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE
REPRESENTING TWO DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES TO DIFFERENT STATES.
BUT AT THIS POINT WE'RE NOT
GONNA WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO OUR
SEPARATE WAYS WE ARE GOING TO
GO. AND GO OUR WAY TOGETHER. WE
ARE TRYING OUR BEST TO BRIDGE
THAT DIVIDE. LIKE EVERYBODY
SAID THIS BILL MAY NOT BE
WHAT'S PERFECT FOR YOU YOUR
FAMILY OR POSSIBLY EVEN FOR
YOUR DISTRICT BUT I ACTUALLY DO
BELIEVE THIS IS THE BEST BILL
FOR THE STATE RIGHT NOW IT WILL
DO THE MOST AMOUNT OF GOOD TO
GET OUR SCHOOLS OPENED UPAND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON AB EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU MR TANG AND WITHOUT
COURT WILL BE THE ROLE. MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS
HER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I. SEVENTY TWO KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION A MEDIA
TRANSMETAL TWO ENROLLMENT.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY FIFTH
THOUGH FOR SESSION-CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY EIGHTH FOR
SESSION AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SAYING IN HER ENOUGH FOR THE
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURNMENTS RAMOS MOVES. MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MARCH THE EIGHTH AT ONE PM AND
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.